she was a presence she was a unifier she  was cool she was calm she was this  passionate I thank her majesty for for  years of unrelenting service she's been  absolutely wonderful and she would be  greatly missed she never explained never  complained she got on with her did the  job and it's just it's just such a shame  that you know she couldn't see the love  in the country for her now even though  we loved her of course we loved her but  here it's just it's been a lovely lovely  time to reflect  and just to say thank you the queen man  I held up a lot to Scotland she was a  hell of a lady and I'm proud to say that  she definitely was the Queen of Scots  she's always been there she's always  always done her Duty for everybody there  must have been many times when she felt  like not getting up and going to work  but she always did not just a thank you  but my heartfelt thank you my lovely  Queen